[Musik]
putin will angeblich Joe Biden treffen
sagt der russische Außenminister lavrov
entspannungensicht nicht so bei Strom
und Gas die Regierung streitet weiter um
die Atomkraft während Experten vor einer
zunehmend Blackout Gefahr warnen viel zu
besprechen heute Abend mit diesen Gästen
Klaus Wittmann ist deutscher Historiker
Publizist und
Brigadegeneral ade der Bundeswehr er
sich sicher mit Putin ist nicht zu
spaßen ich bin sehr gespannt auf seine
Ausführungen Christoph Lüdtke ist ein
deutscher Philosoph von
Wirtschaftsinformatiker eines ist sicher
vor kritischen Worten Schritt dieser
Mann nicht zurück denn er äußerte sich
im Januar 2021 wiederholt als Kritiker
der Maßnahmen zur Eindämmung der
corona-pandemie und wurde aus dem
bayerischen etegrat entlassen schön wenn
man trotzdem bei seiner Meinung bleibt
ihn hier den werden sie kennen den
nzz-politik Journalisten Stammgast
Alexander Kistler seine These ist heute
abend dass die FDP doch lieber die Ampel
verlassen sollte ich bin gespannt Last
bei der Lese Stefan spiegelsberger er
ist Experte für Krisenvorsorge und out
Experte ja die Energie das ist
eigentlich das Thema was uns hier alle
am Tisch aber ja auch die Gesellschaft
so sehr beschäftigt vor allem die Grünen
sperren sich gegen Atomkraft heute aber
machte dann ein Statement pro Atomkraft
die Runde und das kommt von niemand
geringerem ich kann es selbst kaum
glauben als der Grünen Vorkämpferin
gegen den Klimawandel Greta Thunberg
Köln wird auch einmal rein
denke das ist eine schlechte Idee ist
auf Kohle zu setzen solange die AKWs
noch laufen aber für das Klima wären die
Atomkraftwerke die bessere Wahl
zumindest für diesen Moment
es kommt darauf an wenn sie schon laufen
glaube ich dass es ein Fehler wäre sie
abzuschalten und sich der Kohle
zuzuwenden
jetzt spricht sich also selbst Greta
Thunberg für ein weiter Betrieb der
Atomkraftwerke aus das lässt mich zu der
Frage kommen ist Robert Habeck etwa
ideologischer als Greta Tomberg
Alexander küssler ja das ist natürlich
interessant dass man spricht ja manchmal
von Friendly Fire und ist ein
klassisches Friendly Fire also die Ikone
der Fridays for future Bewegung die ja
große Schnittmengen hat mit den Grünen
mit den basisgrünen vor allem in
niedersächsischen Grünen auch sagt nun
letzten Endes ist die CO2-Bilanz
natürlich von einem Atomkraftwerk besser
als von Kohlekraftwerken insofern bitte
lasst doch die bestehenden Fliesen ich
bin der Meinung man sollte Frau toolberg
nicht überbewerten sie ist nicht die
Kindliche Kaiserin nicht das Orakel aus
Nordeuropa den man volle Politiker
man muss ja nicht Schuldigen also ich
habe mal ein Buch geschrieben infantile
Gesellschaft ist mit einem Kapitel drin
aber sie hat natürlich alles rechter
Welt diese Meinung zu haben und sie
zeigt natürlich damit auf dass man im
Zweifelsfall wirklich auch mal den Mut
haben muss pragmatisch zu sein und es
ist bis heute nicht erklärt worden von
Herrn Habig vielleicht jetzt ein
Parteitag am Wochenende in Bonn warum
die zwei wir immer so schön sagt die
zwei süddeutschen Atomkraftwerke weiter
betrieben werden soll das norddeutsche
das niedersächsische aller nicht für
allen wissen dass in Niedersachsen
Gorleben Bewegung die Keimzelle ist der
anti-acker-bewegung aber es gibt ja
jetzt einen riesigen soft zwischen
Christian Lindner und Robert Habeck der
hat sich heute auch noch mal zugespitzt
als politik-journalist kannst du uns
vielleicht mal kurz anreißen warum die
beiden so gar nicht mehr wie er sich
grün sind sie sind sich nicht grün und
ich glaube er habe bereut ist näher
Lindner bereut ist mittlerweile dass er
sich mit einem grünen einen
Kabinettstisch gesetzt hat weil er also
grün wird durch diese grüne grüne
Anwesenheit am kabarettstisch es geht
darum dass er Lindner jetzt auch im Zuge
der schlechten Wahlergebnisse denke ich
mal Niedersachsen zeigen und sagen will
wir setzen durch Vernunft und das heißt
natürlich sie mehr tunbergwagen drei
Atomkraftwerke Herr Habig gesagt es sei
beschlossen worden erstmal nur zwei Herr
Lindner sagt meine Unterschrift also das
Finanzministers bekommt die Einigung
allerdings nur wenn wir alle drei
weiterlaufen lassen die FDP sagt es gab
keine Einigung die Grünen sagen Herr
Habig sei Herr Lindner sein wortbrüchig
geworden das heißt jede Kleinigkeit wird
nun benutzt um ein Zoff hoch zu kochen
und das hier ist eben keine Kleinigkeit
es geht um die Versorgung Sicherheit im
nächsten Winter nächsten Winterhalbjahr
das heißt letzten Endes sollte hier
Habeck muss er habe über seinen Schatten
springen Herr spiegelsberger sie sind
blackout-experte auch und Experte für
krisenversorgung was sagen sie denn mit
Blick auf Robert Habeck ist das noch
verständlich also ich meine selbst
geräter Tomberg die er wirklich ich muss
sagen ich würde sie jetzt nicht so oft
zitieren die klimaaktivisten aber was
sagen sie denn dazu dass die jetzt
eigentlich schon weniger ideologische
Sätze Habeck ja es ist also ich finde es
super weil das Problem an ist ja das
diese drei Atomkraftwerke produzieren
Strom für 10,5 Millionen Haushalte und
durch die Gaskrise und da wir immer mehr
auf Gaskraftwerke setzen in der
Energiewende wir haben ja Atomkraftwerke
gebaut Kohlekraftwerke und diese zum
Großteil durch Gaskraftwerk ersetzt Gas
ist momentan sehr knapp wenn man jetzt
natürlich noch Gas verstrumen müssen
weil sie nicht wie das funktionieren
also ob es funktioniert gehen wir dann
später drauf aber wie gesagt wenn man
die abschalten ist für mich völlig
unverständlich wie man in so einer
Situation der Kernkraftwerk abschalten
kann das weiterhin Strom liefert
Fan bezeichnen das hätte ich nie gedacht
aber heute ja heute sind Sie Greta Tumor
gefahren das ist auch erlaubt denn jetzt
ja vielleicht ganz Deutschland zum Fan
von Greta Thunberg oder besser
formuliert kann zerobert Habeck sogar
dazu bringen weil die Grünen hören ja
schon sehr auf die Community der
klimaaktivisten ja das sollten Sie tun
also und meines Wissens hat sie das auch
schon früher gesagt
also eigentlich ist das gar keine
Überraschung und muss einfach mal auch
über die Landesgrenze hinaus sehen grüne
in anderen Ländern sagen durchaus andere
Sachen als Grüne in Deutschland
in insofern also ich würde da auch noch
nicht zum Fan werden es gibt auch noch
ein paar andere Aussagen aber im großen
Ganzen glaube ich muss man jetzt darauf
setz alle Reserven zu mobilisieren die
da sind und und die nicht mit mit großem
Aufwand erst wieder
also in Gang gebracht werden müssen also
deswegen das glaube ich werden viele
Leute auch nicht verstehen wenn es
wirklich zu Blackouts oder anderen
Krisen kommt wenn hier nicht alles getan
wurde aber es hängt an Scholz er muss
jetzt vermitteln zwischen diesen beiden
Positionen es ist es wirklich seine
Richtlinienkompetenz gefragt der ist ja
in letzter Zeit nicht immer nachgekommen
muss man schon sagen aber jetzt geht es
nicht erkannt diesen Streit nicht
weiterlaufen lassen die Ampel fährt
sonst das Land an die Wand es gibt ja
auch in der SPD viele Atomkraft Gegner
aber er wird man wie würden Sie denn den
aktuellen energiekrieg bewerten den wir
uns befinden
schon seit vielen Jahren ist für
Russland unter Putin Energie eine Waffe
und was die heutige Situation angeht da
warne ich vor zu viel Panikmache auch
seitens des Wirtschaftsministers wir
sind in vielen Dingen in unserer
Wirtschaft eigentlich viel findiger und
flexibler als man das manchmal glaubt
und ich habe eine Sorge dass hier eine
Kriegsmüdigkeit unserer Bevölkerung
Eintritt angesichts der wirtschaftlichen
und sozialen Folgen natürlich ist das
bedrückend aber sollte Putin gewinnen
dann wäre der Preis für uns alle viel
höher als das was wir jetzt an Inflation
und Energiekosten auszuhalten haben
es spiegelsberger nicht zu viel Panik
verbreiten das muss ja eigentlich bei
ihnen klingen man sollte eher noch mehr
Panik verbreiten oder wie würden Sie das
sehen wenn es hilft dass ich die
Menschen dort vorbereiten auf das was
vielleicht kommen könnte dann okay aber
eigentlich braucht man Körper Panik
verbreiten wenn man gewisse
Vorbereitungsmaßnahmen dann für einen
persönlich wäre auch ein Blackout nicht
so schlimm nur leider sind 85% aller
Personen in Deutschland nicht
vorbereitet und das ist eigentlich das
große Problem was mir dann letztendlich
haben beim Blackout ich tue auch dazu
übrigens ich habe mich auch noch nicht
vorbereitet was müs was man jetzt tun
wenn ich mich vorbereiten will ich würde
auf jeden Fall immer nicht alles auf
einmal machen das ist mir das Wichtigste
sondern einfach bei jedem Einkauf zum
Beispiel mal Kiste Wasser mitnehmen
zusätzlich oder mal ein paar Dosen
mitnehmen dass man zumindest dieses
Thema schon mal geklärt hat dann was
viele leider unterschätzen ist es ist ja
stockfinster es geht ja kein
Straßenlaterne es geht kourario es gibt
kein Fernsehen es geht nichts es ist
stille man hört plötzlich Geräusche die
man noch nie im Leben vorher gehört hat
und dann fängt natürlich die Psyche an
einer Streich zu spielen und wenn dann
draußen irgendwas raschelt man hat
vielleicht nicht einmal Taschenlampe
dass man nachschauen könnte ob das jetzt
am aus ist oder ob da jemand draußen
steht dann hat man natürlich ein großes
Problem wenn sie dann ein gewisses
Surren hören dann ist das meine
dynamo-taschenlampe die ich von meiner
Mutter noch habe sie hat einen Bügel und
einfach durch ständiges Betätigen des
Bügels hat man Licht aber nur Reichweite
von drei vier Meter und der moderne
Hotel mehrere hundert Meter Reichweite
hoffen wir mal dass die Dynamo
Taschenlampe dann nicht zum Eingriff
kommen muss zum Einsatz kommen muss aber
Alexander Kistler hat ja heute diese
mitgebracht weil wir machen immer alle
ja auch gerne Robert Habeck für die ganz
große Krise jetzt beantwortlich aber es
gibt noch einen anderen Politiker wo du
der Überzeugung bist na ja so guten Job
macht er jetzt auch nicht ja die die FDP
führt zurzeit ein Italo Western auf der
hieß mal vielleicht erinnern sich der
andere noch daran Leichen Pflastern
seinen Weg heute heißt das Klatschen
Pflastern ihren Weg und die Rede ist
leider von der FDP sie hat 40% ihrer
Wähler Niedersachsen verloren 40 % ist
aus dem Landtag geflogen und es war noch
schlimmer 50% ihrer Wähler hat sie
verloren Schleswig-Holstein und das
konnte sie noch toppen in mir dran
Westfalen in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat sie
60% ihrer Wähler innerhalb von vier
Jahren verloren die FDP befindet sich
auf der Intensivstation in einer
existenzbedrohenden Lage sie redet sich
das schön mit einer staatspolitischen
Verantwortung die sie angeblich
übernehmen müssen ja das muss sie auch
Sie aber schauen dass sie sich als
Liberale Spielerin nicht ganz aus dem
Spiel nimmt das wäre eigentlich ganz
einfach was ist denn liberal mehr
Freiheit statt Bevormundung mehr
Selbstverantwortung statt
Rundumversorgung Staat Skepsis statt
überborden des staatsvertrauen
Chancengerechtigkeit statt Geschlechter
Gleichstellung all diese Punkte
allerdings werden in der Ampelkoalition
von der FDP gefordert zwar aber nicht
verwirklicht sie werden auf dem Altar
der koalitionsrestaurant zum Opfer
dargebracht wenn die FDP morgen noch
überleben will und wir brauchen eine
starke liberale Kraft eine Kraft die auf
Freiheit setzt statt auf Bevormundung
dann sollte sie die Koalition verlassen
solange es sie die FDP noch gibt jetzt
einmal ganz konkret die FDP soll also
die Koalition verlassen da kommt ja
immer das Gegenargument aber ohne die
FDP weil Deutschland noch viel schlimmer
dran also die FDP sagt ja immer bedankt
euch bei uns weil ohne uns wäre es ganz
schlimm natürlich aus einer gewissen
Perspektive richtig wenn vielleicht noch
höhere Steuern wenn eine noch
schlechtere vernünftigere corona-politik
ohne Beteiligung der FDP gleichwohl hat
die FDP das Versprechen gebrochen Anfang
dieses Jahres würden alle
corona-maßnahmen Auslaufen nein sie
laufen nicht aus sie werden sogar
verschärft die Schuldenbremse steht auf
einmal zur Diskussion es ist die Rede
von einer EU-weiten schuldenhaftung also
vom vom verbannen der schwäbischen
Hausfrau und die Rumpelkammer sozusagen
und die FDP muss einfach schauen dass
sie ihre Klientel nicht dermaßen
verspielt dass sie jede Gestaltungskraft
aufgibt und das wäre ja mal schade eine
Partei die sagt wählt uns damit wir das
schlimmere verhindern ist letzten Endes
vielleicht mit Schuld dass das Schlimme
passiert
nicht erst seit der corona-krise wünscht
man sich eine Expertenregierung fast
schon fühlen sie sich dennoch gut
regiert vor allem nach Herr kistlers
Ausführungen also mit der
Expertenregierung bin ich vorsichtig es
gibt ja bei den Philosophen mal dieses
dieses Bild der philosophenkönige die
die regieren sollten das war schon eine
schlechte Idee damals aber auch heute
bin ich nicht sicher ob man wenn man
Experten als Wissenschaftler versteht
und noch mal wirklich sagen würde nie
Botschafter sollten regieren da bin ich
gerade seit der corona-krise sehr
vorsichtig
aber ich stimme also da vollkommen zu
ich glaube die die FDP macht einen
wesentlichen Fehler zu glauben dass sie
sozusagen ganz viele Positionen in der
Bevölkerung in sich vereinen muss wie
eine Partei die 30 Prozent holen will
oder oder wird das wird sie nicht haben
sondern sie müssen die Politik machen
für diese gewählt worden sind von etwa
10 bis 15 Prozent der Bevölkerung
stattdessen ja linke
gesellschaftsprojekte eines nach dem
anderen durch wir leisten uns den Luxus
einer diskrimin diskriminierungsbereiten
antidiskriminierungsbeauftragten Namen
Frau attermann also wir haben ein
Mikromanagement in kleinste Vorgänge
hinein der Gesellschaft der Stadt wird
übergriffiger es soll Menschen verboten
werden Menschen nach dem
Geschlechterwechsel noch mit dem alten
Namen anzureden etc pp dass die Linke
Projekte für die man aus linker Sicht
kämpfen kann aber es gibt irgendwo auch
die rote Linie und ich habe den Eindruck
dass momentan die rote Linie der FDP
elastisches Band ist
spannenden Punkt gebracht dass die FDP
ja eh keine Volkspartei ist noch nicht
sein wird sondern eine Klientelpolitik
macht und dafür auch gewählt wird das
Spannende ist ja in Niedersachsen dass
die Grünen ja sogar Gewinne noch
einfahren konnten zusätzliche die Grünen
sind aber ja auch sehr von ihrer
kernwählerschaft Weg nehmen wir mal die
Abkehr vom Pazifismus nehmen wir das mit
den Atomkraftwerken kann man nicht
eigentlich fast schon sagen dass die
Grünen Wähler einfach zu blöd sind zu
merken dass sie verarscht werden und die
FDP Wähler aber leider zu klug sind um
es nicht zu merken oder ist es zu
drastisch also sie haben das jetzt
gesagt vielleicht kann man das als Frage
extra formuliert also da über die
Klugheit oder nicht in dieser Wähler
will ich mich nicht äußern aber ich
glaube in der Tat das ist das da was
dran ist wir die Parteien müssen
erkennen wofür sie stehen wofür sie
gewählt wurden auch in besonderen
Situationen wir brauchen einen
Liberalismus immer der Liberalismus und
ein bisschen in die Geschichte sehen hat
es in Deutschland immer schwer gehabt
und es gab auch Phasen in denen er sich
völlig neu aufstellen musste und es kann
durchaus sein dass wir wieder in einer
solchen Phase sind dass wir
möglicherweise dort eine andere
Strukturierung dieses Liberalen Angebots
in der Politik brauchen ich glaube das
ist durchaus so weit ist das müssen das
muss sich jetzt dann auch zeigen als
Philosoph warum hat es der Liberalismus
so schwer in unserem Land
ja das ist eine das ist eine wirklich
gute Frage
sind die Deutschen von sich aus
liberaler manche würden das vielleicht
so sagen die Deutschen sind sind zu
konservativ oder auch zu
autoritätsgläubig ich bin mir nicht
sicher ob das stimmt also ob das so
pauschal nur stimmt es gibt sicherlich
Aspekte davon und wir haben in
Deutschland zwei Diktaturen erlebt aber
ich glaube nicht dass das der einzige
Grund ist sondern ich glaube manchmal
auch dass die Angebote die gemacht
werden in der seitens der Politik nicht
gut genug es war ich finde es nach wie
vor eine Folge des überbortenden
Sozialstaats wir eben unser Bismarck
begonnen hat dass man sich dran gewöhnt
hat in Deutschland mittlerweile im
dritten Jahrhundert schon wenn ich ins
19 zurückschaue der Staat ist letzten
Endes der große Ernährer und er darf
deshalb auch der sein der sagen wo ich
zu denken habe das ist ein großes großes
Problem dass man das kurz schließt die
Ernährung die eigentlich nur in
Sicherheitsnetz sein sollte mit der
Kompetenz sie haben den Staat zuspricht
über richtiges und falsches Denken zu
urteilen es ging schon bei bis zusammen
einerseits Sozialgesetzgebung
andererseits Kampf gegen Katholiken und
gegen Proletarier er wird man
sicherheitspolitisch werden Neuwahlen
jetzt ein großes Risiko
Neuwahlen ja wenn die Ampel kollabiert
oder die FDP sagt wir sind raus dann
wird es ja neu reingeben also in dieses
auf dieses Thema möchte ich mich gar
nicht einlassen ich glaube alle in der
deutschen Politik haben erkannt dass
äußere Sicherheit mit innerer Sicherheit
viel stärker verbunden als früher eine
Grund ein Grundbedürfnis ist das
befriedigt werden muss und dass wir 30
Jahre lang uns in der Sicherheit gewiegt
haben dass wir nur von Freunden umgeben
sind ohne zu beachten dass unsere
Freunde nicht von Freunden umgeben sind
den Balken haben wir gesagt nur werdet
man nicht hier hysterisch wegen Russland
die polnische Kritik an Nord Stream 2
und der Abhängigkeit von Russland haben
wir nicht erkennen wollen also ich
glaube jedwede
Konstellation wird in der
Sicherheitspolitik ähnlich handeln
müssen wie das jetzt
erkannt worden ist und
ob man dann vielleicht die Zögerlichkeit
in der Unterstützung der Ukraine in
anderen Konstellationen anders sehen
würde das ist teilweise auch eine Frage
der handelnden Person eine Zahl 63% der
deutschen sagen diese Parteien bringen
uns nicht durch die Krise es sei denn
alarmierendes Signal auch
sicherheitspolitisch wenn wir auf
Deutschland blicken und nicht
außenpolitisch blicken
ich bin ja im nebenfachhaus Soziologe
gewesen ich glaube nur der Statistik die
ich selber gefälscht habe um das alte
Hormon noch einmal zu bemühen und da
kommt es immer darauf an wie die Frage
gestellt wird und bringt uns durch die
Krise die Krise hat viele Seiten und
mein Metier ist hier mehr die
Sicherheitspolitik dazu sage ich auch
gerne gebracht innere Sicherheit innere
Sicherheit gehört dazu und gerade für
eine rechtsstaatspartei wie die FDP
müsste eigentlich die innere Sicherheit
ein starkes Feld sein und wenn man sich
in Koalitionsvertrag anschaut kommt
innere Sicherheit eigentlich unter
ferner liefen nur vor das heißt auch da
sehe ich eine Bringschuld der FDP die
sie gemeinsam mit eigentlich auch an
Sicherheit interessierten Kräften
innerhalb der SPD viel stärker nach
vorne bringen könnte stattdessen wird
also viel getan und die Delegation
unserer staatlichen Institution
voranzutreiben also Bundeswehr Polizei
werden teilweise teilweise unter
Generalverdacht gestellt und da bräuchte
es auch eine starke selbstbewusste
Verfassungstreue rechtsstaatspartei wie
die FDP die sagen auf dem Boot unseres
Grundgesetzes schützen wir alle die sich
zu ihm bekennen Herr spiegelsberger sie
auch als Bürger gefragt wie empfinden
Sie denn die Lage in unserem Land
dramatisch würde ich ganz einfach mal
sagen also was von der Politik in die
letzten Jahre eigentlich gekommen ist
das heißt mit der corona-krise mit dem
Maßnahmen oder auch jetzt wie gesagt ich
kann solche Sachen nicht verstehen dass
man überhaupt auf die Idee kommt
Atomkraftwerke jetzt abschalten zu
wollen oder die es war viel zu spät dass
man jetzt sagt die Kohlekraftwerke
sollen weiterlaufen und dann auch nur
für drei Monate was machen wir im
nächsten Winter es ändert sich ja nichts
so kurzfristig und insofern muss ich
sagen was momentan in der Politik
passiert ist definitiv nicht für uns
Bürger
ich war heute tanken zum Beispiel ich
war vor kurzem in Italien unten ich war
in Kroatien da ist der Sprit um 50 60
Cent günstiger als bei uns in
Deutschland und ich frage mich die
kaufen ja nicht teurer ein also muss es
ja irgendwo an der Steuer oder sonstiges
liegen und ich verstehe nicht dass die
Politik hier dann jetzt sagt die Firmen
haben alle ich bin seit Jahren
selbstständig ich rede mit viele
Firmeninhaber die haben alle riesen
Probleme sei es Materiallieferungen sei
es natürlich gestiegene Kosten
gestiegene Löhne die wissen gar nicht
wie sie das nur reinbringen wollen und
es haben viele Firmen draußen die
Mittler eigentlich kurz vorm Kollaps an
und im Gegensatz zum unseren
Wirtschaftsminister sage gehört wenn der
Firma nichts mehr verkauft dann ist die
Kongress da werden wir alle am Tisch
zustimmen aber wie sie haben uns heute
nicht die Preise mitgebracht sondern vor
allem die Blackouts oder der Blackout
der kommen könnte und ohne jetzt ein
Horror Szenario würde ich mir trotzdem
gerne ihre These anhören also es ist
immer so schön dass in die Medien quasi
erklärt wird ja die Speicher sind zu 94%
voll das klingt super das Problem dabei
was ich aber leider sehe ist ich werde
zum Beispiel gastechnisch lieber in
Lettland die haben nur 53 Prozent in die
Speicher drin die Frage ist ganz einfach
wie lange reichen die Speicher bei den
letzten reichen die 110% des Jahres das
heißt selbst wenn die kein Gas mehr
bekommen sind die ein yourself bei uns
ist es so wenn man die Tabelle Neustadt
noch die 94% drei Spalten rechts daneben
steht 25,6 Prozent und das ist es was
von unserem Jahresbedarf tatsächlich in
die Speicher verfügbar ist und immer
dann weißt dass man von Oktober bis
April rund 75% unserer Speicher
eigentlich also unseres Jahresverbrauchs
verbrauchen dann haben wir momentan ein
Drittel von dem Gas das man benötigen
das ist die große Frage ob es reicht das
was man momentan importieren im
exportieren mehr leiten ja viel Gas
einfach nur durch und das neueste ist ja
jetzt dass uns dieses Gas das wir mit
Steuermillionen ja Milliarden kaufen gar
nicht gehört oder mir Verkaufsrecht oder
sowas haben und wenn natürlich das Gas
ausgeht dann haben wir im Gegensatz zur
Meinung mancher Politiker natürlicher
Stromproblem weil wir noch nie so viel
Strom
so viel Gas verstromt haben wie zuvor
weil man eben durch die Energiewende von
Kohlekraftwerke auf Gaskraftwerke
umgestellt haben und dann ist es
natürlich nicht verwunderlich dass man
im September 2015 ein Gigawatt Gasstrom
hatten und die letzten September hat man
bis zu zehn Gigawatt
wenn der Blackout dann kommen sollte was
passiert da genau
also wenn tatsächlich definieren
Blackout ich nehme hier die Definition
des Bundesamt für Bevölkerungsschutz und
Katastrophenhilfe der geht dann
mindestens drei Tage lang und betrifft
mehrere Bundesländer alles andere ist es
sogenannte wir nennen das brownout
großflächiger Stromausfall und wenn es
tatsächlich zu einem Blackout kommt dann
ist natürlich klar stellen Sie einfach
mal vor Sie sitzen daheim was geht die
noch in ihrem Haus ohne Strom
was geht man es geht nichts mehr auch
kein EC-Automat mehr gehen um Bargeld
erzielen es geht kein Supermarkt mehr es
geht die Tankstelle nicht mehr hat der
Batterie man hat Kerzen haben wir doch
jetzt alles zu Hause ja wenn man die
daheim hat ist die schon mal guter
Anfang es geht die Wasserversorgung
nicht mehr das ist zum Beispiel was was
die meisten leider vergessen gerade die
wir mit diesen Sprudler daheim haben die
haben ja keine Wasserflaschen mehr
gelagert und die meisten haben die
meisten Wasser versorgen kann für so 24
Stunden bringen die Wasser und dann noch
was ist und es gibt dann kleine
Nebeneffekt davon dass natürlich ja die
Toilettenspülung da nicht mehr
funktioniert und das ist natürlich ein
sehr unangenehmes Problem weil wie wird
man eigentlich Blackout Experte das habe
ich mich heute schon den ganzen Tag
gefragt auch wenn ich ihn jetzt höre
auch mit der Toilette wie kommt man auf
diesen Beruf wie kommt man auf diesen
Beruf tatsächlicherweise habe ich vor
vier Jahren wieder das Buch Blackout
gelesen von Mark Elsberg mein
Lieblingsbuch muss ich sagen und dann
hat mich einfach mal interessiert wer
ein Blackout in Deutschland möglich und
ich bin gelernte Energieanlagen
Elektroniker war aber jetzt lang in der
anderen Branche tätig und dann habe ich
mir einfach unser Stromnetz mal
angeschaut ich war entsetzt wie sich
unser Stromnetz in den letzten 20 Jahre
verändert hat wie viele
eingriffsmaßnahmen jetzt notwendig kann
wir haben früher im Jahr drei bis sechs
Mal eingegriffen letztes Jahr 8600 mal
und dieses Jahr haben wir letzte Woche
die 10.000 der Grenze überschritten von
Eingriffen sogenannten
redispechmaßnahmen um die Stromnetz noch
stabil zu halten und es zeigt einfach
wie instabil dass unser Stromnetz ist
und jetzt kommt natürlich die Gaskrise
noch ein Top und wer wird dann helfen
also wenn der Blackout dann da ist
dieses Horror Szenario die Bundeswehr
wie funktioniert das dann
also ich nenne es mal ich sag's mal mit
den Worten von der Hauptfrau von
Vorarlberg die einfach gesagt hat es
braucht keine erwarten dass dort jemand
der Butterbrot schmiert und ist auf dem
Silbertablett ich selbst bin Helfer
Katastrophenschützer beim THW also
ehrenamtlich und ich muss sagen wir
werden tun was wir können aber wir sind
viel zu denke ich müsste wir haben
80.000 THW da haben aber schon 16.000
Kinder mit drin und das heißt jeder von
uns müsste für 1000 Leute alleine ihr
Gartenparty schmeißen was zum Essen
organisieren das ist also in keinster
Weise möglich und wir haben im Alltag
gesehen da waren 40.000 ja nur betroffen
und da waren eigentlich die Katastrophen
die ganzen Helfer schon eigentlich am
Limit und jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor
es wären 4 Millionen betroffen oder
vielleicht sogar 40 Millionen aber es
ist ich meine es ist daran
Szenario und sie es klingt in ihren
Worten jetzt so also ja irgendwann in
diesem Herbst Winter kommt halt der
Blackout 3 bis 5 Tage schaut dass er
dies und jenes macht wir reden noch nach
wie vor und diese Hoffnung möchte ich
mir heute abend nicht rauben lassen auch
von ihnen nicht wir leben doch nach wie
vor in einem Szenario und dem das sehr
sehr unwahrscheinlich ist oder leben wir
nicht von Promille oder reden wir von
zehn Prozent wir reden von weit weit
mehr das sagen Sie jetzt nee das sollte
nicht das sagt sogar die
Bundesnetzagentur nämlich habe Kurt der
vor kurzem diese gastszenarien
vorgestellt haben sie mitbekommen und
ohne russisches Gas waren von diese
18-Jährigen dann quasi in einer
gasmangelage wo es für mich die
Katastrophe ist weil man in dem Moment
müsste man dann einfach den Strom die
Gaskraftwerke reduzieren und es wird
vielleicht dann also wenn man zu wenig
Strom dann im Netz haben kommt
vielleicht die Schweizer Modell die
Schweizer Regierung hat bereits im Juni
angekündigt ein Modell ist zum Beispiel
du hast vier Stunden Strom du hast vier
Stunden keinen Strom du hast vier
Stunden Strom vier Stunden keinen Strom
und sowas in die Richtung könnte dann in
Deutschland auch kommen wenn wirklich
der Strom zu wenig wird und momentan
sieht der dann auch aus ich hoffe es
ändert sich noch
das ist halt dann wie gesagt bei jedem
wieder anfahren wenn das alles wieder
anspringt dann läuft jeder Kühlschrank
los jede Maschine läuft los jede
Elektroheizung läuft los jede Wärmepumpe
und das ist die sogenannte stromgear das
ist das was jeden Netzwerktechniker die
schweißstirn auf die
Schweißperlen auf die Stirn bringt
einfach aus dem Grund weil man dort das
vier bis zum zehnfachmann Strom brauchen
und der glühende Leitungen dann fällt
irgendwann die Sicherung
sehr ungläubig bei der Szenario
Beschreibung nein ich verlasse mich da
auf die Experten und ich bin Experte für
Sicherheitspolitik und als solcher hier
eingeladen damit beschäftigen mich im
Augenblick ganz andere Fragen das muss
ich wirklich sagen sie haben mich
vorgestellt hier mit der These mit Putin
ist nicht zu spaßen ich habe genau das
Gegenteil gesagt von Putin sollten wir
uns nicht einschüchtern lassen und ich
habe die Sorge dass die Verängstigung
auch bei unserer politischen Klasse
durch seine letzten Schritte also die
Annexion der Gebiete die er jetzt als
Russland erklärt die Teilmobilmachung
die nuklearen Drohungen und jetzt die
gestrigen intensiv noch zu ihrem Blog
wir machen kurz mit dem Blackout zu Ende
und dann werde ich ihr das vorstellen
mit mit Putin ist zu spaßen oder wir
werden dann noch mal darüber reden wie
wir es vorstellen werden Gedanken wollte
ich ja noch mal kurz aufgreifen wenn Sie
gesagt haben erst seit 20 Jahren neben
die Eingriffe ins Stromnetz und Strom
das ist ja Teil der Infrastruktur immer
mehr zu das heißt wir reden hier offen
16 Jahren Frau Merkel wir reden von jede
Mengen großen Koalition kleinen
Koalitionen was es überall gab in den
Ländern und daeinsvorsorge Infrastruktur
ist durch die Kernaufgabe unseres
Staates müssen wir uns also da weigere
ich mich eigentlich aber müssen wir uns
an das Bild gewöhnen dass 16 20 Jahre
lang der Staat seiner Kernaufgabe
nämlich der Daseinsvorsorge nicht
nachgekommen ist da hätte ja fast
sämtliche Legitimationen verspielt
verliert eine Frage habe ich auch an sie
was macht das eigentlich psychologisch
mit uns allen diese Krisen und ich würde
nur kurz ergänzen weil weil sie vorhin
Lettland angesprochen haben ich war
nämlich zufällig gerade in Lettland und
es ist in der Tatort überhaupt gar kein
Thema das ganze auch ich war dann auch
in Litauen es ist kein Thema die die
Energie Frage auch in anderen Ländern
ist es wird überhaupt nicht darüber
diskutiert
also dann wenn das so wäre dann hätte
man wirklich in Deutschland über Jahre
hinweg geschlammt und dann wäre also der
Staat Kernaufgaben nicht nachgekommen
und das ist wirklich ein Problem und das
hat dann natürlich auch auch und gerade
diese psychologischen Auswirkungen denn
es ist ja manchmal nicht nur dass die
die Krise selbst und die Angst vor der
Krise die die vielleicht kommt die Krise
ja gar nicht also es gibt noch eine
Chance dass sie nicht kommt würde ich
sagen aber aber auch die Angst macht
etwas mit den Menschen natürlich und die
Menschen die auch gerade zweieinhalb
Jahre corona-krise auch mit mit Regeln
sich psychischen Auswirkungen schweren
mentalen Auswirkungen erlebt haben auch
gerade auch für die junge Generation
aber auch andere und jetzt dieses jetzt
doch da drauf ich glaube das ist immer
etwas was sich so für einen wie soll man
das sagen so ein mentales Gesamtbild
einer Bevölkerung glaube ich keine gute
Entwicklung ist und darum mache ich mir
Sorgen ja man sieht es ja auch schon an
den Zahlen das nehmen ja auch schon
Suizide zu vor allem in der corona-krise
haben die zugenommen aber auch
Depression ich frage mich oft was es mit
den heranwachsen macht mit der
Generation die jetzt eigentlich
heranwächst
ja da beobachten wir genau das was Sie
gesagt haben und
ich meine früher gab es mal die no
future Generation aber die hatte
eigentlich keine wirklich Angst in
diesem Sinne also die hat ja eigentlich
gar nicht erlebt das waren ja so eine
Ehre des bezog sie auch was anderes aber
heute glaube ich schon das ist das das
und das wir können das sehen an den
Zahlen wie gehen das Menschen gerade
jüngeren Menschen sich grundsätzliche
Sorgen darüber machen ob sie wirklich in
einer guten Zukunft leben werden ob sie
diese den Lebensstandard den sie jetzt
haben halten werden und das muss noch
nicht bedeuten dass sie davor Angst
haben dass sie Hunger leiden werden oder
richtig in Armut rutschen sondern dass
sie einfach den Standard nicht halten
können und und Abrutschen werden über
Krise Nummer eins die wird zumindest so
wahrgenommen und da muss ich zumindest
dann das Lob für Frau thumberg wieder
einkassieren Krise Nummer eins in der
Wahrnehmung heranwachsen ist die
sogenannte Klimakatastrophe also es
wächst wirklich eine Generation heran
von großteils oder vielen verängstigen
jungen Menschen die also wirklich der
Meinung sind also 10 oder 20 Jahren geht
die Erde unter wenn wir nicht sofort aus
allen fossilen energiestoffen aussteigen
und dieser Angst vor der
Klimakatastrophe ich halt schon das Wort
falsch vor der Klimakatastrophe führt
eben dazu dass viele kein zutrauen mehr
haben auch ihre eigene
Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten das finde ich
ist ganz ganz schlimm wenn Menschen
heranwachsen ohne zutrauen dass sie in
dieser Welt wirklich etwas bewegen
können
und was kann man dagegen tun ich glaube
man kann nur appellieren an die
zukunftsorte zunächst einmal es ist
nicht es ist nicht ruchlochbar es ist
nicht verboten optimistisch zu sein
kreativ zu sein Menschen können erfinden
es gibt keine eingängigen Wege es gibt
immer Alternative die Katastrophe wurde
schon hundertmal ausgerufen sie hat noch
nie also der Weltuntergang noch nie
stattgefunden die Apokalypse lässt auf
sich warten also ich glaube Panik ist
kein guter Ratgeber weder beim Blackout
noch bei Frau Thunberg
Panik ist kein guter Ratgeber ist ein
schönes Schlusswort für diese These wir
gehen eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung dann
wieder zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter bauen und
ich ernst nehmen also genannten Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach fünf Köpfe fünf
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi Wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz an das
Auto das wäre ganz nett das sind
irgendwelche anorakträger aus Buxtehude
die das Gucken ich habe meinen Beifall
in meine lache immer bekommen wer
kümmert sich darum niemand bitte ist
Baden ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt mal
auch darüber sprechen dass es einfach
nicht fair ist und nicht richtig Aufgabe
von Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und jetzt kommen wir zu
einem sehr ernsten Thema und das ist
selbstverständlich der Krieg in der
Ukraine und da hat uns Herr Wittmann
heute seine These mitgebracht
ich möchte damit anfangen dass ich sage
ich höre immer das Reden von den zwei
Kriegsparteien das ist bereits eine
Verharmlosung und vergessen wir nicht
welchen Charakter dieser Krieg hat es
ist eine brutale
unterwerfungsoffensive gegen ein
souveränes Nachbarland zum Zweck von
dessen Zerstörung und Auslöschung seiner
staatlichen Identität verbrecherisch
nach Absicht und Ziel und auch nach den
Methoden jetzt gerade die gestrigen
Bombardements von Wohngebieten und zu
ziviler Infrastruktur wenn Sie Herrn
lavraf hier zeigen der jetzt plötzlich
Schalmeien Töne
ausstößt und spricht davon spricht man
wäre zu Verhandlungen bereit ja zu
Verhandlungen bei denen das was bisher
annektiert ist in russischer Hand bleibt
und über den Rest können wir verhandelt
das ist nicht ernsthaft und viele in
unseren in unserer Gesellschaft die
wollen Waffenstillstand sofort
Verhandlungen sofort das ist völlig
illusionär solange Russland überhaupt
keine Bereitschaft zeigt von seinen
Zielen
abzugehen und was Putin gemacht hat ich
hatte es vorhin schon eingeflochten
Teilmobilmachung Annexionen Verwandlung
der Gebiete in russisches Territorium
nucleare Drohungen terror-bombens das
sind verzweiflungsakte und wir sollten
uns dadurch nicht ängstigen lassen
sondern wir sollten das zum Anlass
nehmen zu sagen jetzt kriegt die Ukraine
wirklich alles was sie braucht zur
Flugabwehr
zur Verteidigung und auch zur
Wiedereroberung von
weggenommenem Territorium womit sie ja
schon große Fortschritte gemacht hat und
das einschließlich Panzer und
Schützenpanzer das ist ja das
kontroverse Thema und ich glaube der
Bundeskanzler der sollte sich jetzt
einen Ruck geben und sagen jetzt ist es
genug und wir geben die Ukraine nicht
Preis er sagt ja immer die richtigen
Sachen bei seiner Zeitenwende Rede vor
den Vereinten Nationen jetzt mit den G7
aber die konkreten Konsequenzen daraus
die sind mir zu schwach zu zögerlich zu
spät und hätte man Ende April als der
Bundestag die Regierung beauftragt hat
schwere Waffen zu liefern entsprechende
Entscheidungen getroffen dann wäre viel
Gerät längst im Einsatz und viele
Ukrainisch leben werden wahrscheinlich
auch gerettet worden sie halten also
Putins Atomwaffen beispielsweise für ein
Bluff wenn er selber sagte es ist kein
Bluff dann ist es wahrscheinlich einer
aber es gibt auch rationale Gründe mit
denen man daran gehen kann anstatt jetzt
sich erpressen zu lassen wer sich
erpressen lässt hat schon verloren und
wird weiter erpresst und Nuklearwaffen
sind heute zur Kriegführung nicht mehr
geeignet sondern nur noch zur
Abschreckung und wie gesagt zur
Erpressung gegenüber dem der sich
erpressen lassen will
ist gibt bisher kein Anzeichen für eine
Änderung in der russischen nuklear
poststa wie man sagt also die
Stationierung die amerikanischen
Geheimdienste sind sehr gut
informiert sollte Putin tatsächlich eine
Atomwaffe einsetzen da wäre schon der
erste Einsatz einer sogenannten
taktischen Atomwaffe die größer sein
kann als die Hiroshimabombe etwas was
uns in eine ganz andere Welt
katapultiert übrigens wären Indien und
China die beiden großen Mächte die ihm
noch so einigermaßen die Stange halten
zumindest die nicht öffentlich
verurteilen äußerst ungehalten darüber
und es gibt auch Kontakte zwischen den
Regierungen in den USA und Russland und
auch zwischen den Militärs in den
Informationen und Warnungen
weitergegeben werden also ich nehme es
ich nehme es ich nehme es als
Verängstigung versucht der Spaltung des
Westens besonders die German Angst ist
ja allgemein bekannt auch in Russland
und
ich glaube nicht dass es soweit kommt
ich kann natürlich nicht in seine
gehirnbindung schauen aber putin wird
eskalieren egal was wir tun oder was wir
unterlassen aber sie haben am Anfang in
ihrer Vorstellung der These gesagt dass
auch Verhandlungen so was wie aufgeben
wären viele Menschen wünschen sich aber
natürlich Verhandlungen weil die moralis
auf ihrer Seite aber die Vernunft spielt
ja auch eine Rolle und glauben Sie dass
durch die schweren Waffenlieferungen und
wenn das alles passiert der Krieg
wirklich beendet wird mit ihrer
Expertise also der Krieg wird nur
beendet wenn Russland bereit ist an den
Verhandlungstisch zu gehen unter Aufgabe
eines Teils seiner Ziele diese Ziele
sind ich habe es ja eingangs gesagt die
Zerstörung der Ukraine die Vernichtung
ihrer staatlichen
Identität die Ukraine hat kein Recht zu
existieren und wenn meine Überzeugung
stimmt das Putin nicht wirklich Angst
vor der NATO hat sondern davor dass sein
eigenes Volk vom demokratischen Virus
angesteckt wird dann wird er bei der
Ukraine nicht halt machen sollte er
seine Ziele durchsetzen deshalb habe ich
vorhin auch gesagt egal was jetzt an
Informationen und
Energiekosten uns bedrückt der Preis für
uns wird viel höher werden wenn Putin
sich durchsetzt davon bin ich überzeugt
und Sie können auch nicht sagen dass
Deutschland mit dem Verzicht und sagen
wir mal es ist uns jetzt eine egal mit
den Energiekosten sagen wir mal die
Inflation ist uns auch egal sagen wir
mal es ist völlig egal dass wir der
kranke Mann Europas und auch das ist uns
egal aber kriegen wir denn damit Putin
an den Verhandlungstisch können Sie
sagen wenn wir jetzt verzichten schaffen
wir eine Lösung für die Freiheit ich
habe gesagt es ist sehr bedrückend aber
der Preis wird höher werden wenn Putin
sich
und in karpaccinol vor drei
durchsetzt
bei einer Konferenz hat
idealov russische Dissident sich
geäußert glauben Sie bloß nicht dass ich
an der russischen Spitze was ändert es
wird kein Staufenberg geben es wird
keinen neuen Gorbatschow geben die
Bevölkerung die Oligarchen die Militärs
forgettet und dann hat der Moderator
ganz verzweifelt gefragt gibt's nicht
irgendwas was zu einem Wechsel an der in
der russischen
Machtkonstellation führen kann da sagte
ja nur dass ukrainische Militär nur wenn
Putin einsieht dass er seine Ziele nicht
erreichen kann dann wird er zu anderen
Bedingungen als denen die er jetzt
vorträgt an den Verhandlungstisch gehen
und dann gibt es seriöse Verhandlungen
Politikwissenschaftler wissen ganz genau
das Verhandlungen der Beginn von
Verhandlungen keinen Zweck hat solange
die eine Seite sich auf der sie Straße
fühlt ich glaube nicht mehr das Putin
auch wirklich auf der Siegerstraße ist
aber das ist ja die herrschende Meinung
in Russland dass man ununterbrochen der
Bevölkerung erzählt die militärische
spezialoperation geht nach Plan hilf
gesehen sie einen anderen Weg wie mein
Putin an den Tisch holen kann gibt es da
vielleicht auch philosophische Ansätze
also vom Grundsatz ist es sicherlich
richtig dass man Stärke zeigen muss um
jemanden an den Verhandlungstisch zu
bekommen also von einer schwachen
Position aus ist es sehr schwierig
auf der anderen Seite glaube ich müssen
wir noch mal eins sehen da würde ich
gerne mal einen Haken was ist mit der
Verhältnismäßigkeit was ist mit der
Verhältnismäßigkeit der Mittel also wenn
es tatsächlich so ist dass wir in uns
bei insbesondere in Deutschland gar
nicht so sehr in anderen europäischen
Ländern ein immer stärkeres Problem
kriegen in Sachen Inflation in Sachen
Energiepreise riskieren wir da nicht
auch andere sozusagen Kollateralschäden
dieser Politik die auch schlimm sein
könnten ich meine nur zu sagen
das andere ist das schlimmste was
passieren kann also das ist mir zu
einfach gibt es nicht noch irgendwas
dazwischen also gibt es nicht auch einen
Punkt an dem man sagen würde also die
diese Schäden die wir hier erzeugen sind
doch zu groß und wir müssen
etwas an unserer Politik ändern
wir erzeugen keine Schäden
wir erzeugen keine Schäden das ist eine
Funktion eine Funktion dieses Krieges
ich habe in unserer Vorgespräch habe ich
ja gesagt ich bin Mitautor der
friedensdenkschrift des Rates der EKD
von 2007 als einziger Soldat ich bin
durchdrungen von der protestantischen
Friedensethik Prävention Absage an
militärische Lösungen
Grenzen rechts erhaltender Gewalt
Vorrang und ziviler Konfliktbearbeitung
aber wenn Sie ein Gegenüber haben einen
Despoten der in seinem außenpolitischen
Arsenal nichts anderes hat als nackte
militärische Gewalt dann muss er
zunächst mit militärischer Gewalt
gestoppt werden und auch zurück gedrängt
werden und dann können wir weiter reden
und eins noch man hört von den
Befürwortern Waffenstillstand sofort
Verhandlung sofort hört man auch ohne
Gebietsabtretungen wird es für die
Ukraine nicht abgehen die Bedenken nicht
dass abzutretende Gebiete Dörfer und
Orte und Regionen sind in denen
Millionen von Ukrainern dasselbe
passieren wird was unter russischer
Besatzung in anderen Regionen schon
gewesen ist und ich brauche gar nicht
aufzuzählen Vergewaltigung Folter
Plünderung und so weiter ich muss eher
mal an Einzelheit denken Deportation
Deportationen von universellen
Menschenrecht kommen weil dann könnten
wir jetzt auch ist es ist leider so
müssen wir jetzt auch mit Kriegen in
anderen Regionen anfangen was da mit den
Menschen passiert das ist natürlich
furchtbar aber wenn wir mal einmal auf
den Punkt bleiben weil ich glaube jeder
ist sich hier sicher dass es eine
Kriegspartei gibt und einen
Angriffskrieg ich hoffe das müssen wir
hier nicht klarstellen dass es natürlich
logisch aber alle sind ja bemüht um die
Lösung und was ich mich frage ist wie
weit und das war glaube ich auch Ihre
Frage Herr Lüdtke wie weit müssen wir es
militärisch schaffen damit Putin an den
Verhandlungstisch kommt wie viel Waffen
werden reichen wie viel Menschen leben
wird es noch Kosten das ist ja die Frage
die ganz viele Bürger auch umtreibt wird
der Krieg 10 Jahre gehen wird er
Kommentare gehen das sind ja alles
Fragen die man gestellt das fängt mit
davon ab wie wir die Ukraine militärisch
stärken denn es hat sich ja jetzt schon
gezeigt die russischen Streitkräfte sind
nur in einem überlegen in der Feuerkraft
masse statt Klasse und sarkastisch
gesagt in der Brutalität ihres Vorgehens
so wie wir das im Westen und auch seit
stockreine nicht machen auf allen
anderen Gebieten operative Planung und
Führung taktische Beweglichkeit
Führungssystem Aufklärung Kommunikation
Logistik und vor allen Dingen in der
Motivation sind die Ukrainer überlegen
und was sie mit den begrenzten Mitteln
die sie bisher bekommen haben schon
erreicht haben dass es unglaublich und
jetzt haben sie durch die
zurückgelassenen Panzer mit Munition der
Russen beinahe schon mehr zusätzliches
Kriegsgerät als der Westen ihnen bisher
geliefert hat und ich glaube mindestens
mindestens die
Wiedergewinnung der Gebiete die bis zum
24 Februar noch nicht unter russische
Herrschaft waren ist die Ausgangslage
für Verhandlung davon bin ich überzeugt
und ganz besonders der Bezirk Carson ist
in so vieler Hinsicht wichtig
Landwirtschaft ist das Tor zur Krim der
nord-krimkanal der stepping stone
gewissermaßen für einen Angriff auf
Odessa und so weiter als ich bin
überzeugt davon ich sagte vorhin
Verteidigung
Flugabwehr in viel stärkerer Maße nach
dem was wir jetzt gerade erlebt haben
mit den Angriffen auf 20 Städte zivile
Infrastruktur Wohnhäuser
Kinderspielplatz und so weiter und dann
auch die gepanzerten Gefechtsfahrzeuge
zur Wiedereroberung von einem
nennenswerten Teil ukrainischen Bodens
damit Putin einsieht so geht es nicht
Herr Gisler wie ist denn die die
Stimmung im politischen Berlin ja die
Stimmung ist fast so zum kippen würde
ich mal sagen wie wir sie auch in den
anderen Debatten in der Ampel die wir
vorhin kurz skizziert haben wahrzunehmen
ist die Frage nach der
Verhältnismäßigkeit der Mittel die
stellt sich eben durchaus auch jetzt
schon gerade im politischen Berlin weil
man natürlich in einer Demokratie von
Wahl zu Wahl hechtet auch wenn es jetzt
erstmal eine Weile Ruhe ist aber wir
haben permanent Meinungsumfragen wir
sehen dass die Zustimmung für die
Ukraine immer noch deutlich über 50
Prozent ist dass sie aber abnimmt
insofern wie gesagt die Frage nach der
verhältnisgleich der Mittel ist
keineswegs trivial die Frage aus dem
politischen Nebenkosten wird sich auch
irgendwann Stellen der Punkt ist ja auch
nicht von der Hand zu weisen dass
natürlich die Politiker ein Eid
geschworen haben Schaden vom deutschen
Volk abzuwenden ihre Position für dich
große Sympathie habe heißt der Schaden
für das deutsche das deutsche Volk wäre
umso größer wenn Putin gewöhne das ist
richtig aber es kann auch hier genauso
mit der Klimadebatte womöglich an einen
Kipppunkt kommen wo es eben ein
jahrelanges darben gibt ein jahrelanges
investieren in einen Frieden ohne dass
man den Eindruck hat er kommen näher und
dann kommt das wirklich näher der
sogenannte Zahltag bei der Demokratie
nämlich der nächste Wahltag und dann
habe ich wirklich die große Befürchtung
dass wir dann mit dieser Rhetorik die
sie teilweise hier angeschlagen haben
wir müssen gegen die Kriegsmüdigkeit in
Deutschland angehen dass man dann glaube
ich auf nur noch eine Minderheiten
Zustimmung treffen wird weil ich glaube
das Gegenteil von Kriegsmüdigkeit wäre
Kriegs Begeisterung das kann es auch
nicht sein also es muss ein vernünftiger
rationaler Umgang sein und noch einmal
die Fragen nach Verhältnismäßigkeit der
Mittel und nach dem was Deutschland
wirklich Front wird von Tag zu Tag
drängender und sie kommt ins Zentrum der
Debatte also ich würde sagen den
Kipppunkt sollte man nicht dabei reden
und die öffentliche Meinung die hat auch
mit politischer Führung zu tun aber
irgendwann
und ständig rumlaviert dann ist das
etwas anderes als wenn man die Dinge die
ich hier
geschrieben für starke Waffen an die
Ukraine und dennoch immer diese ewig
weitermachen mein kraftvoll zum Ausdruck
bringt und erklärt dass das ist meiner
Meinung nach eine Führungsaufgabe verbal
tut der Kanzler ist ja komm wir machen
hier einen kurzen Schnitt weil wir
kommen zur These von Herr Lüdke und ich
fand vor allem auch bei Kistler am Ende
dann wünscht sich ja auch oder auch bei
ihnen Ausgewogenheit in der Debatte die
hatten wir jetzt glaube ich gerade das
ist schön jetzt kommen wir zu Ihnen Herr
Lüdtke
ja ich glaube dass die gegenwärtige
Regierung riskiert die Bevölkerung zu
überfordern mit ihrer Politik und das
betrifft nicht nur einen Bereich sondern
es betrifft mehrere das betrifft die
immer noch nicht ausgestandene
corona-krise die politisch hätte schon
längst beendet werden können gehen in
den meisten anderen europäischen Ländern
auch aber das betrifft natürlich jetzt
die Ukraine Krise die in eine
Energiekrise wir haben darüber
gesprochen überführt wurde und wird und
ich befürchte einfach dass es hier
Gegenreaktionen geben wird seit der
Bevölkerung wir sehen es schon jetzt in
den Wahlen ein bisschen auch dazu dass
die Menschen glauben sie können diese
Sorgen nicht immer mehr äußern das haben
wir in der corona-krise auch erlebt und
das ist auch jetzt hier wenn man ist
einfach zu schnell dabei Kritiker und
andere Stimmen abzustempeln eine Ecke zu
schieben und im Grunde ist es zu
versuchen sie mundtot zu machen und das
ist eine Art von Politik die irgendwie
letztlich auch von Demokratie am Ende
wegführt und von der Meinungsfreiheit
und im Pluralismus den wir haben wurden
sie von Markus Söder mundtot gemacht als
den integrat verlassen mussten ah das
ist ja nicht gelungen aber ich hätte
natürlich schon lieber in auch in diesen
Ethikrat mit meinen Ideen bereichert und
ich glaube es hätte auch dem Ethikrat
genutzt
aber natürlich lasse ich mich jetzt
nicht mundtot machen was allerdings auch
nicht das wird für sie angefühlt ich
habe wirklich ich habe das damals auch
verfolgt habe gedacht eigentlich kann
das ja nicht sein dass jemand kritisch
ist oder kritisch den corona-maßnahmen
Gegenüber ist und dann gibt es einen
Politiker in dem Fall Markus Söder der
dann dafür sorgt dass das jetzt nicht
mehr so angebracht wird ja das weiß er
das plattformuliert aber also ich so
etwas in der Art hatte ich auch zu dem
Zeitpunkt noch nicht erlebt auch noch
nicht wieder seitdem
[Musik]
also sozusagen diese unmittelbare dieser
Versuch der Politik einzugreifen in eine
eigentlich als unabhängig geltende
Expertise das ist etwas was ich auch
nach wie vor als ein absolutes No-Go
ansehe und
was dann auch glaube ich zurückschlägt
anschließend denn
wenn man wenn man wirklich hier versucht
in gerade in wissenschaftliche
Unabhängigkeit ja in irgendeiner Weise
in irgendeiner Weise also restringierend
einzugreifen sozusagen
dann wird das an anderer Stelle wird
anders zum Nachteil und ich glaube das
kann man durchaus auch sehen wo war wo
war der wo war der Knackpunkt also was
glauben Sie rückblickend hat das fast
dann zum Überlaufen gebracht das gesagt
wurde sind zu kritisch ja es sind ja
auch es sind zwei Dinge dass das eine
ist ich habe deutlich Kritik in den
corona-maßnahmen geäußert ich habe den
Lockdown deutlich kritisiert bereits
Ende 2020 dann Anfang 21 noch mal auch
dann dass er immer weiter verschärft
wurde ich habe auch andere Maßnahmen
kritisiert und dann habe ich aber auch
diese Kritik öffentlich gemacht und ich
glaube dass das manche der Meinung sind
man muss sich in man darf zwar die
Kritik äußern aber nur hinter
verschlossenen Türen und ich glaube das
ist ein Fehler also gerade auch wenn es
um Ethik geht muss man diese Debatte in
die Öffentlichkeit tragen und und das
habe ich vorher gemacht das habe ich
auch hinterher wieder gemacht den das
ist für mich kein Verständnis von Ethik
Ethik lebt von der Debatte auch wie mein
klassisch bei den Griechen und dem
Sokrates der auf den Marktplatz ging und
mit den Leuten diskutiert dann so
einfach kann es sein natürlich ist es
heute ein bisschen komplex aber man muss
die Themen nach in die Öffentlichkeit
tragen und nicht hinter verschlossenen
Türen diskutieren und das weiß ich auch
heute ganz aktuell das werfe ich auch
anderen vor ich ich glaube auch dass wir
das Thema Ethik was ja eigentlich von
Ethik reden auch auf der bundesdeutschen
Ebene betrieben werden sollte dass das
nicht ausreichend und auch nicht in der
Ausgewogenheit betrieben dort bis heute
eigentlich also dieses muss es müssen
dort stärker kritische Stimmen gesehen
werden und zwar nicht nur hinter den
verschlossenen Türen und es ich beklage
eine schon also seit letztem Jahr
mindestens eine fehlende Ausgewogenheit
dort ein ganz aktueller Fall ist ja das
Buch von Brecht und Wälzer das wird ja
hart vor allem von Journalist ich komme
gleich noch darauf was Herr Kistler zu
dem Beruf sagen wird ich bin gespannt
aber ist das für sie auch eine Form wir
Diffamierung der öffentlichen Meinung
ja also das ist ja interessant weil ich
in vielem Brecht und Welter eigentlich
nicht zustimme in im Film sind wir
völlig unterschiedliche Ansicht aber in
diesem Punkt dass sie sagen es findet
eine Verengung der öffentlichen Meinung
statt es es findet eine Verengung in den
in den klassischen Medien statt ich
glaube genau das haben wir beobachtet in
den letzten zwei Jahren sind da würde
ich voll bei dem sein und und ich ich
sehe auch diese Mechanismen die da
stattfinden in interessanterweise sind
ja Brecht und Welter die äußern sich
nicht auf den sozialen Medien
interessanterweise
das fehlt natürlich aber wir können ja
auch nicht sagen ja gut wir haben jetzt
als die sozialen Medien als Gegenstimme
gegen die klassischen sondern es muss
auch in den klassischen Medien müssen
diese Stimmen erkennbar sein muss es
möglich sein auch abweichende Meinung zu
äußern ohne dass man gleich diffamiert
wird
Alexander Kessler wie sehen Sie das denn
mit dem Blick auch auf das Buch von
Brecht und Wälzer es hat ja die
Journalismus Branche schon zum beben
gepreist weil ich so viel gesagt aber es
wurde ja direkt mit dem typischen das
ist alles falsch reagiert so hatte ich
das Gefühl falsch ist natürlich der Satz
der über mich drinsteht ich werde heute
also auch ein schlechtes Licht gestellt
dann muss ich natürlich in aller Form
zurückweisen ich mache durch alles
vorbildlich irony of das Buch hat
natürlich die Schwierigkeit dass die
beiden natürlich alle Protein haben die
sie Meinung haben kann sie sitzen in
großen Show sie haben eigene Formate
also den beiden wurde und wird nichts
verboten zumindest die letzten fünf oder
zehn Jahren die bestimmen sogar viele
Debatten muss man ganz klar sagen
dennoch machen sie natürlich einen Punkt
dass wir vor allem am Beginn der
coronakrise teilweise vielleicht obwohl
ich da jetzt nicht so scharf sehe am
Beginn auch der Debatte und Ukraine
Krieg doch den Eindruck hatten die
Medienöffentlichkeit wollte das Mädchen
Publikum in eine bestimmte Richtung
drängen also nach dem Motto man kann
zwar schon anderer Meinung sein aber
dann gehört man halt nicht dazu also du
kannst schon sagen irgendwie Corona ist
vielleicht nicht so schlimm oder lässt
sich nicht impfen Klammer auf aber dann
willst Du halt vielleicht auch das Opa
stirbt Klammer zu das heißt man wurde
gewissermaß mit einer Meinung die
zunächst mal legitim ist in den Rand des
menschenfeindlichen gerückt und das sagt
glaube ich sehr sehr schlimm sehr sehr
falsch es ist danach auch besser
geworden und vor allen Dingen darf man
auch nie vergessen was für eine
Signalfunktion es hat für kleine
Debatten wenn man in großen Debatten
eine Meinung überrepräsentiert sieht
dann gewinnt vielleicht auch jemand der
zu Hause zuschaut weniger zutrauen sich
zu seiner eigenen abweichenden Meinung
zu bekennen aber wenn ich prächt und
Wälzer richtig verstanden habe hier muss
ich einmal kurz noch einhaken dann ist
es nicht so dass sie sagen es würde
keine Meinung gehört werden das ist ja
auch ganz richtig analysiert Brecht und
welche sitzen überall aber ich muss
sagen die Hämmer die über Herr Wälzer
beispielsweise ausgeschüttet wurde oder
über Herr Precht zeigt ja schon ja man
darf dann seine Meinung sagen aber ist
ja auch immer das Gegenargument da muss
man mit dem dem Sturm dagegen halt leben
wenn es aber nicht die Medien sind da
würde ich gerne hätte als Philosophen
einmal fragen wenn es nicht die Medien
sind sagen wir mal die Verengung gibt es
nicht in den Medien woran liegt es denn
dann dass viele Bürger und da gibt's
Umfragen zu unter 50% trauen sich noch
ihre politische Meinung zu sagen laut
dem einspracheninstitut woran liegt das
denn diese Schere im Kopf die man
anscheinend selber empfindet also meine
Vertrauensverlust der da stattgefunden
hat offensichtlich also was gegenüber
dem Medien geht gegen auch überall gegen
der Politik natürlich ja also es hat
natürlich Erosion von Vertrauen auch
schon vor der corona-krise geben aber
nie so dramatisch
ich glaube Menschen haben einfach
erfahren auf die Dauer hier kann etwas
nicht stimmen hier wurde uns immer
gesagt wenn wir diesen Lockdown jetzt
beenden dann wird alles ganz furchtbar
die Zahlen steigen es wird alles ganz
furchtbar und irgendwann das glaubt man
auch eine Weile eine Weile glaubt man
das aber irgendwann merkt man auch ach
Moments ganz so schlimm kann es nicht
mehr da kann es dann wohl doch nicht
gewesen sein das ist glaube ich eine
Meinung die sich auch in weiten Teilen
der Bevölkerung mittlerweile verbreitet
hat wenn man sieht wie wenig Leute
mittlerweile mit den Maske in diese
freiwilligen Supermarkt gehen das macht
man dann einfach nicht offenbar ist man
dann der Meinung auch obwohl Zahlen
steigen das ist vielleicht doch nicht
ganz so gefährlich ist also das meine
Erfahrung die man macht glaube ich
führen dazu und denn es ist glaube ich
nicht so sehr das Interesse für für
Herrn Brecht selber oder für Herrn
Wälzer also gut die sehr werden
natürlich auch gelesen das ist richtig
aber es ist glaube ich etwas man liest
nicht das man fühlt sich nicht abgeholt
man in den Leser das ist doch eigentlich
klassisch auch der abholen wo er oder
sie ist
ja aber bitte kurz halten weil wir haben
nicht gesendezeit ja
ich habe auf einer Autofahrt durch
Norddeutschland dem NDR ein langes
Gespräch mit den beiden gehört wo ihr
Buch war nein wo ihr Buch vorgestellt
wurde und ich kann nur zu einem Aspekt
was sagen wie die beiden Leitmedien
herrschende Meinung gegen Meinung werden
nicht gehört auf den ukraine-krieg
angewandt haben das habe ich als eine
sehr naive Relativierung des
offensichtlichen
betrachtet und empfunden nicht das
Offensichtliche der verbrecherisch
Charakter die Menschenrechtsverletzungen
all diese Dinge da braucht man keine
Gegenmeinungen um die Tatsachen zu
Kenntnis zu nehmen ich hoffe das
verzeihen Sie mir zu sagen ist es
manchmal ganz gut das Buch zu lesen war
ein Interview wird immer ganz dem gewahr
das habe ich selber schon bei mir erlebt
aber damals
ausführlich vielleicht lesen sie es
trotzdem mal und damit wünsche ich Ihnen
doch auch am Ende herzlichen Dank an
meine Gäste und morgen abend sind wir
wieder für Sie da tschüss schönen Abend
noch
[Musik]